[موسيقى]
أثناء عملية الحداد ،
نحافظ كأطفال على مسافة آمنة
بينك وبين الآخرين
[موسيقى] ،
إنه أمر مخيف بعض الشيء ، أعتقد أنه نظرًا
لما تحب أن تلتقطه
متفاجئًا بصدق لأنني قاتلت في الواقع
بناءً على فيروس كورونا الذي نجلس عليه
كنت قريبًا جدًا
من الفكرة التي شعرت بها بشكل أفضل بعد أن
ذهبت إلى موقع American Airlines
وقراءة سياسات متطلبات الأقنعة الخاصة بهم
وحول حقيقة أنهم كانوا يحاولون
عدم بيع كل مقعد على طائراتهم
في محاولة لإبقائنا في مواجهة بعضنا البعض
ومع ذلك ، فقد كان ممتلئًا بشكل مدهش
لم ألاحظ أي مقاعد متاحة وكنت
من آخر الأشخاص الذين استقلوا
الطائرة ،
وهي تقنية جلوس جديدة
تتكون من أجنحة يمكن نشرها
من ظهر المقعد بمجرد نشر الراكب
للجناح الذي يعطي
مستوى أكبر من الدعم الجانبي حتى تتمكن من
الاتكاء عليه للحصول على الراحة نظرًا
للموقف الذي نحن فيه جميعًا قمنا بتطويره
إلى أضواء الفضاء وهو في الأساس
مجموعة أدوات يمكن الالتزام بها في المقعد الأوسط
في الاقتصاد الثلاثي وخليج المقعد ، نحن
نعمل بجد لتسويق هذه الأشياء
بأسرع ما يمكن لأننا
نعلم أن الوقت جوهري وهو
شيء يتعلق كثيرًا بالتأكد  أن
يشعر الركاب بالأمان
[موسيقى]